[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm Kip EHD here and
this is Samsung's new flagship with the
Galaxy S 20 I actually kind of like that
they're catching up the name to the year
so 2020 Galaxy S 20 now I don't know
that they'd say this ever publicly but
if you went to Samsung and just asked
hey what's the most important phone that
you guys make every year what's the most
influential phone in your lineup will be
this it will be the new galaxy s
flagship this is the phone that the
average person sees as the Android
iPhone competitor as as the big nemesis
and when you have such a big reputation
to protect you tend to not take as many
risks you want to make the right safe
moves in the right places and then take
the risks with other phones so I have my
buddy gender here whose youtube channel
is your average consumer to help me out
with this one so you should definitely
check out his channel link below so
without any further ado let's get into
galaxy s xx so Samsung made some moves
with this phone and they're all around
pretty great
it's a new high refresh rate display a
bigger battery a new camera system and
5g pretty simple safe but all good moves
so I'll start with the display because
it's the best upgrade so you might
remember I was harping all of last year
on how much I love high refresh rate
displays and there were naysayers but
now we're all slowly I guess realizing
how good it is
now Samsung's on board with the galaxy s
20 and we've got a super fluid 120 Hertz
display it's also point 1 inches bigger
and flattened out a bit on the edges so
this is the biggest best change for the
galaxy s 20 I'm a gamer so when I'm
gaming and if the phone support I have
the game supports 120 Hertz it's a it's
a whole nother level guys it feels so
different from regular games that you
just fall in love immediately there are
certain types of games also that take
that look better at 120 Hertz like I was
just playing a golf game and you know
it's you know the ball flies through the
air and it's smooth and everything but a
racing game where you're really trying
to react quickly and stuff is coming at
you real quick flying across the screen
there's less tearing that's where 120
Hertz looks amazing
yeah and like I said
if a month it's a month so needless to
say I'm a huge fan of the high refresh
rate I've been saying it but also
something you notice in pretty much
every phone that's moving up to the high
refresh rate is a bigger battery to keep
up with it and so galaxy s 20 also does
that moving from thirty four hundred to
a four thousand milliamp hour battery on
paper that's pretty good that's a
substantial gain it's almost twenty
percent bigger and you also still have
the wireless charging and you have up to
25 watt fast charging but at the end of
the day you just want battery life to
hold up
alright so battery life how's your
battery been I don't want to spoil your
video and I'm sure you'll go into detail
on it but generally on s 20 what's that
been like I mean I can pretty
confidently hit five hours uh maybe even
slightly under that but we're talking
about 4,000 milliamp hours and 120 Hertz
always-on right so I'm not gonna say I'm
I'm pretty happy with it I mean that's
like that's a whole day like getting to
the end of the day no problem oh yeah
yeah for me it's been about the same
like a five-hour screen on time day is
pretty good there are some days where I
might need more and so I can kill this
phone in a day mm-hmm I don't think I
could say that about like that 5,000
6,000 milliamp hour phones but yeah I'm
comfortable with the battery at 120
Hertz yeah I I mean you'll see a
difference between this and like the
ultra yeah for sure I think so
I didn't give him the fact that here you
are using it at 120 Hertz yeah it's
worth the trade-off 120 hours is that
good to me it feels like an even trade
between high refresh rate and battery
life meaning this phone got up to 4000
milliamp hours and didn't really gain a
ton or lose a ton of battery life the
ultra still has better battery life with
that even bigger battery but overall I'd
give this phone a solid b-plus and then
of course if you really want to save
battery
protip you can it's like it comes out of
box of 60 here it's put pro tip you can
switch it back down to 60 Hertz and you
will gain tests say around 30 percent
battery life by switching down so if
you're about to have a super long day
and you know you won't have access to a
charger you can switch down to 60 Hertz
fine longer battery life but the rest of
the internal specs as a reminder are
bumped up to 2020 flagship numbers which
are just crazy big numbers across
the board so snapdragon 865 12 gigs of
ram across everyone 128 gigs of ufs 3.0
storage to start and all great
performers and as I expected this phone
performs great actually it performs
every bit as great as the s20 ultra
that's something we don't talk about as
much is the ceiling for performance in
these high-end phones is pretty
consistent and in a brand new phone you
know going from 12 to 16 gigs of ram
doesn't make that much of a difference
right now so the s20 doesn't stutter or
a lag or have any problem multitasking
or holding apps on the RAM any worse
than the ultra in case you were
wondering alright I got an average
consumer question for you okay cuz I'm
apparently out of touch okay does the
average consumer miss this headphone
this is the first headphone jack being
gone from a samsung flagship it was gone
from the note 10 but like this is the
default Android phone the headphone jack
is gone no is that is this a big moment
for that it's it's a big moment I'd say
because I think it's just the
willingness people are to accept that
it's gone yeah
Samsung has been one of the last
companies to really hold on to it yeah I
agree I know headphone jack not a big
deal for me it's been like three years
now of me not using a phone with the
headphone jack I have my wireless
headphones but yeah I've complained
about it for a long time
yeah and then after a while I noticed a
lot of people in my comment section
would just be like dude get over it like
Oh am i I'm trying to defend you guys
house if you're with it but okay if I
stop kind of knocking companies for
taking it away yeah you're still gotta
have the headphone jack there's a couple
options left
but this is no longer one of them so the
new camera system the last big change in
these phones is kind of funny it's a 12
megapixel main camera with oh is a 12
megapixel ultra wide camera and a 64
megapixel 3x telephoto camera so of
course the specs are a bit worse on
paper but the camera experience of the
s20 in a couple of ways is actually
better than the s20 ultra that's mainly
because the s20 ultra had a couple
issues that the s20 doesn't have plus a
couple of things that the s20 ultra does
specifically better than most like zoom
aren't necessarily enjoy
or applicable to everyone so a typical
photo from the galaxy s 20 camera is
sharp first of all some may find the
look over sharpened actually at times
but you can't ever really complain that
it's soft and Samsung has continued to
tone down and Dow back what used to be
this crazy saturated and vivid colour
complex to now a more neutral look that
I like and I still think it works it
definitely still likes bright exposures
though and it will air on the side of
overexposure sometimes but generally it
takes nice photos plus I've had none of
the s20 ultras autofocus issues thanks
to dual pixel autofocus being back here
and the sensor being smaller also
technically means the fringing at the
edges that I talked about with the s20
ultra is less of a problem I'm actually
seeing less involuntary bokeh and less
close focus smearing and then zoom will
get you to a maximum of 30 X instead of
a hundred x but i still find that's
plenty that's enough for me like I
mentioned before I usually just zoom
with my feet but in the few instances
where I can't you will get crisp or
faraway shots with just this telephoto
I mean videos are pretty solid
especially if you're using like the
super steady that's really it looks so
good yeah I can shoot b roll with this
and probably get away with it really I
think so I think for the average person
oh yeah yeah that's true but for us
maybe maybe not but I think regular
people using this for video they're not
gonna have any complaints like things
are a bit sharp you know but for the
most part yeah pretty solid so the 4k
video on this phone looks good
8k video while it's available and that's
amazing it's still kind of compromised
again it's still 24 fps
still has some rolling shutter and has
no tracking autofocus but really the
main thing is it doesn't even come from
the main camera this time it comes from
the higher resolution 64 megapixel
telephoto camera which means it crops in
a lot and is just generally harder to
use
so I'd stick with the 4k video for the
most part for safety so they hit the big
three with the right moves with camera
battery and display they're all better
but then they have to be smart about
preserving keeping the familiar good
stuff which they also did a lot of with
s20 so they kept the ultrasonic
fingerprint reader and it
fine you know they kept the speaker at
the bottom of the phone that's fine they
still have one UI of course and all
their 25 million features still ip68
water-resistant still expandable storage
it's actually better button placement
meaning they got rid of the bixby button
now they still have the hole punch
camera up at the front it's moved to the
middle now but it's still a small cutout
and really they just kept the same
general design aesthetic and materials
from galaxy s 10 I mean it's a glass
sandwich in the spirit of figuring out
the average consumer I did a little poll
on Twitter to try to figure out how many
of you guys use a case on your phone and
if I was guessing I would have said
something like 60 65 percent but it was
closer to 80 percent of you so if you're
looking for a case for the galaxy s 20
might as well check out the grip case
from channel sponsor D brand I don't
have it here but I think Andrew does
over there on the other side of the
studio you got the one with the teardown
skin on it let me get that one over here
so yeah the grip seems to work pretty
well it's pretty protective so yeah like
I said a lot of the right moves these
phones also now have 5g across the board
s 20 tests 20 ultra but the regular s 20
only supports low to mid band 5g while
the s 20 plus and ultra AD millimeter
wave so you all know how I feel about 5g
I already have said you probably
shouldn't buy these phones just for 5g
but it's worth noting this will never
have millimeter wave 5g but now that
we've seen what Samsung has improved and
we've actually used it this definitely
still looks and feels like the default
Android phone which if you're gonna
compete this is the thousand-dollar
phone you got to measure up to and if
you want to charge more than that you
gotta beat it at something and I feel
like that's exactly what Samsung wanted
and they're still happy to have that
spot so big thank you and shout out
again to gender for the collab you
should check out his day in the life
video I'll link it below the like button
where he goes over all the little
nuances and things you find using a
phone like this on a daily basis but
that's the galaxy s 20 is it the best
phone no it's not even Samsung's best
phone in their lineup that would be the
ultra but this is a better Buy so this
is the new default who's gonna beat it
that's been it thanks for watching catch
you guys in the next one peace